ouais qu'est-ce qui a maintenant elles
sont pas bonnes mais coquette vous en
avez pas marre de les critiquer sur
install bons messieurs dames aujourd'hui
j'ai un stress particulier avant de
faire cette vidéo là c'est une grosse
grosse grosse pression c'est revoir ce
challenge le confinement où beaucoup de
gens ça a été l'occasion de découvrir
quelque chose sur eux mêmes y en a qui
sont aperçus qu'en fait ils adorent et
la lecture qu'ils adoraient finalement
le cinéma qu'ils adoraient méditer moi
j'ai découvert qu'à part des pâtes et du
riz je ne savais rien faire en cuisine
hockey et c'est particulièrement pas
normal car c'est un besoin vital
et c'est un besoin vital de se faire à
manger deux voix deux sphères qui fait
qu'une arme en parlant et je suis pas
foutu de faire des oeuvres plein d
europe lâché même pas dire le mot c'est
bon bref comme d'hab je comble mes
lacunes dans quelque chose en faisant
une vidéo sur le sujet parce que ça me
donne la force d'essayer alors que si je
fais pas une vidéo je n'ai pas la force
d'essayer j'ai la flemme vraiment j'ai
le niveau zéro genre ceux qui me suivent
sur un staff vous étiez outré parce que
mais moi j'étais content mon gars de
faire mes potes c'est comme tom nook
j'étais content je montrais mes
coquillettes et m'ont ri et j'en faisais
tu en as ta maman j'ai la même chose
elle varie un peu
regarde ce que j'ai fait en cinq minutes
baird laissez moi tranquille avec mes
potes et maureen ans il est vrai un
repas sur 10 je varie un peu je me fais
des raviolis au micro ondes
c'est vraiment ce que je mangeais quand
j'étais au lycée le midi quant à qu'une
heure et que tu rentres chez toi au
sprint en bref aujourd'hui gros
challenge
on va s'attaquer à un plat qui est assez
dur à faire j'en ai parlé autour de moi
les gens m'ont juste dit tu n'y
arriveras pas mais laissez-moi essayé
bordel nous allons aujourd'hui cuisiner
des raviolis farcis à la tapenade
d'olives les ingrédients sont ici la
vidéo tuto et là on va faire et ça va
donner des très bons a violé je me suis
un peu tu franchement j'ai fait a donné
pour l'image le son bon comme d'hab on
est confiné on fait ce qu'on peut avec
ce qu'on à bref allez donc on va vous
parler des pâtes fraîches déjà bonjour
excusez moi les pâtes fraîches c'est
donc d eux la farine de blé tendre un
peu d'huile d'olive fleur de sel
toujours ça c'est ma touche et dlouhy
s on fait de la cuisine sur la chaîne
cfoot j'aurais jamais dit est ce que je
serais capable de faire ça séchait pas
cuisiner évidemment ça n'a rien à voir
alors on va commencer avec anne of
casser un oeuf dans un cul-de-poule
d'oakland ron est en train de faire la
pâte des raviolis quelle est la
différence entre un ravioli et une
raviole
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
oh non regardez on a notre of la suite
environ 5 grammes d'héroïne attend donc
ce gars est tellement bon qu'il n'a ni
balance ni verts qui mesurent la il
sélection tout en plastique
combien de grammes de farine il a pris
très bien alors déjà il faut le mettre
le bol dessus pour que ça prenne pas en
compte le poids du bol et ensuite on
ajoute la famille il a dit environ 100
grammes environ mondial enquêtent dans
quelle recette on dit environ fins et de
la chimie tout ça c'est au gramme près
ya pas de environ chez insupportable
sans un gramme parfait je vais réussir
et ça va vous trouver une q et ça va me
trouver le cul encore plus que vous la
farine ce fait on est sur 102 grammes
finalement il a bien fait de dire
environ ça me rassure beaucoup
combien d'huile d'olive compères du
d'olive je vais en mettre un pouvoir on
va voir le dossier
[Musique]
ça suffit voilà là je pense qu'il y en a
trop
elle plus c'est gros plus on se régale
je m'en fous partout
ok la suite comme je n'aime pas trop
mais c'est les mains j'ai commencé avec
une cuillère battant moi non plus j'aime
pas trop me salir les mains ça tombe
bien je te remercie chef grande petite
cuillère j'ai l'impression que chaque
détail compte tu insupportable peut-être
mais voilà travailler ah ouais à temps
il ya eu un cut là il a tout y est dix
minutes au moins avant d'avoir sa non ok
je suis prêt et mais je crois que je
vais y arriver mais qu il ya zéro blague
au même si j'y arrive ça va trouver le
cul de tellement de gens je voudrais pas
être harry hole à la mecque j'ai fait
une pâte
vous voyez ce que je veux ou quoi la
hoya elle est pas comme la sienne ça y
est c'est le début du petit stress
chronique alléno stress lucas c'est
normal a été peut-être un peu plus
travaillée la scène ok donc là il
rajoute un peu de farine
et là on la travaille 8 et ce mouvement
là ça me fait pour ça la pâte à modeler
j'ai envie de faire un pikachu d'un coup
quand j'ai dit à tout le monde en fait
on fait des pâtes qu'il faut parler avec
les potes à les [ __ ]
c'est un laminoir
on l'appelle comme ça hein quoi ça c'est
un laminoir laminoir à ok c'est pour
aplatir sa patte j'en ai pas donc qu'est
ce qui va se passer
eh bien à l'ancienne mon pote comme la
grande malle faisait on a un rouleau on
va le faire la main nous et c'est ça les
vrais chefs c'est ce qui qui mène au ça
marche on fait la cuisine et on fait du
sport non mais j'ai pas compris là c'est
pas si mal la taille je crois que
vraiment je suis en train de m'en sortir
voilà ouais c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
je pense que la dernière étape c'est de
le faire sur la table directement on va
mettre de la farine pour pas que ça
colle et que ça se brise quand je le
retire donc on va y aller sans trop
appuyer et puis plus le temps va passer
plus je vais mettre à appuyer
[Musique]
je vous jure que c'est pas si mal
ok franchement ouais franchement c'est
pas mal je sais c'est une sale gueule
mais franchement c'est pas mal attendez
[Musique]
moi elle est une bête de forme sa patte
avoir la mienne elle et elle n'a pas la
même forme quoi moi je vais la coupe et
des cours étant cette façon
ok donc je vais couper comme ça attaque
tacle n'y a plus aucune blague là
maintenant ok c'est bon on veut juste
des bords à violer la fin de la vidéo
[Musique]
tout cela est très dangereux
et maintenant en quarts et messieurs
dames après un travail acharné
je possède tout mais rectangle enfin car
et excusez moi on peut passer à la suite
les farcir avec de la taper un tollé à
vélo et de l'eau après mon mari comme ça
ok on met la tapenade au milieu on
humidifie les bords et on ferme en
triangle let's go j'adore la tapenade
d'olives par contre ça me fait penser
genre c'est quand tu es dans le sud de
la france au soleil en terrasse et là on
est confiant ça va vous alors moi je les
douze bien je déteste mon gars quand
même des trucs fourrés et que c'est
quasiment pas fou et genre le pire comme
ça c'est les pains au chocolat dans tous
vos chocolats thing on s'en bat les
couilles bon pendant cette anecdote n'ai
pas vu le temps passer mais la tapenade
et présenté dans les raviolis alors on
humidifie les bords ont pu entrer en jeu
c'est parti que ces longs que c'est long
[Musique]
et de un ça a de la gueule on dirait les
gâteaux chinois de chance là mais pas du
tout c'est un ravioli de ce cui 6 et
voilà je sais c'est irrégulier mais ça
n'empêchera pas le fait qu'on va bien se
régaler c'est quoi la suite chef comme
ben kouider abily super important
toujours bien salée la halle au départ
alors ça c'est une technique moins étant
un pro des pâtes c'est une technique
effectivement saler l'eau et ça va
beaucoup mieux salé le tout comme ceux
des pâtes fraîches sur va courir très
vite une minute environ
et juste à côté d'eux confondu peur avec
caen produits d'olive au [ __ ] c'est
l'étape de la cuisson
j'espère qu'ils sont bien j'espère
qu'ils sont bien à temps avant de passer
à l'étape de la question je viens de
comprendre un truc là j'ai pas fais des
raviolis j'ai fait des samoussas mais
voilà j'ai un peu de 200 libanais moi ok
les plaques les plaques les plaques les
plats qu'on va mettre l'eau à bouillir
sf renard ok je vais appeler lorraine
pendant que ça cuit pour voir ce qu'elle
en bourse
c'est vrai quoi quoi on pourquoi tuerie
non non non franchement mais bien sûr
c'est pas si mal
brossez irrégulier mais vas-y c'est
hyper dur de faire le même truc à chaque
fois tu vois mais franchement je suis
fier 1-0 mi-temps tuerie bassin certes
il faut que j'avance je te rappel après
a de suite
bon
[Musique]
j'ai une valeur tout onze top
la boutique
oh la la c'est tellement dangereux non
mérite d'être dans notre salon
messieurs dames loup est en train de
bouillir c'est maintenant que je mets ça
une minute là dedans je veux mettre une
alarme parce que je me suis fait foiré
mon timing c'est le pire moment c'est un
peu le moment de vérité aussi c'est pour
ça que forcément ses pires moments c'est
un peu comme tu passe ton bac c'est le
moment de vérité est ce que tu as
travaillé cette année ou pas cette année
désolé ok je suis prêt top chrono ces
partis ne vous ouvrez pas ne vous ouvrez
pas pitié
ok dès qu'elle monte à la surface c'est
gagné ça va faire une minute dans pas
longtemps
elles montrent elles sont en train de
monter ça fait une minute une minute
vingt invasive à dire que c'est bon on
va directement au delà d'une minute
maintenant c'est dans la poêle
j'ai qu'une poignée est-ce que je suis
un énorme tube et on y va on secoue
ça
qu'est ce qu'un poisson
il y en a plus c'est bon faut faire quoi
correspond la pole donc je pense très
sage
combien de temps la place combes maire
de tours c'est pas évident et on merde
voilà ça c'est ça résume bien ce qui se
passe je crois qu'en fait comme ma patte
était plus épaisse que la sienne parce
que j'ai pas le séchoir là j'aurais dû
les laisser plus longtemps dans l'eau
qu'une minute passe comme la pâte est
plus épaisse ça met plus longtemps
écrire donc là je suis en train de faire
griller entre guillemets dans la poêle
des raviolis pas assez cuit en fait je
suis abattu
ça va finir chez dans la gamelle de
natsu on va rien comprendre
moi je pense qu'on est bons ils montrent
au centre de l'assiette mais franchement
c'est pas si mal attendant je vais c'est
chaud après c'est le dressing qui joue
pour beaucoup je vais essayer de faire
un bête de dressing et peut-être ça nous
sauver
[Musique]
et franchement elle française a de la
gueule un peu en vrai en vrai ça un peu
de la gueule vous préférez les siennes
ou les miennes mec je te jure qu'elle
vienne sont plus belle après est ce
qu'elles sont meilleures
c'est une autre question
[Musique]
mais cet homme il est temps de goûter
franchement ça a l'air bon mais ouf 0
blague même si c'est pas bon temps que
ça est comestible je ne mangerai je veux
pas gâcher surtout quand cette période
c'est parti
je vous jure que c'est bon mais alors
est-ce que ça aux signes quand tu vas
manger un truc que tu aimes pas du bon
pour le faire passer non j'aime vraiment
juges avaient soif et j'ai pas bu depuis
une heure
franchement je crois juste que c'est pas
si tu lui quoi je n'ai pas assez cuit
dans la casserole mais ça reste
comestibles et b veut appeler lorraine
[Musique]
non mais attends tu veux pas explosé de
rire et à prédire alors ils sont pas mal
moi je vais dire tout haut ce que tout
le monde pense tout bas moi je vais dire
tout ce qu'on pense moi je pense que
sans les contraintes liées au
confinement donc avec genre les bons
ingrédients et tout je pense qu'ils
auraient été à la hauteur de que de ceux
du chef c'est trop d'énergie et de temps
pour un résultat pas d'un way
[Applaudissements]
écoutez je vais être honnête avec vous
c'est superbe de cuisiner c'est hyper
intéressant transformer en fait c'est
cool d'avoir la matière il a transformé
en quelque chose est d'arriver à un
résultat
je suis content c'est pas mauvais c'est
cool bon c'est juste pas assez cuite
mais mec j'ai passé une heure vingt à
faire ça en fait le temps que j'ai passé
en plus par rapport à un coquet tendon
bleu tu vois n'est pas justifiée par la
différence de plaisir quand je mange ça
par rapport à quand je mange des côtiers
de cordon bleu et je pense que c'est ça
mon problème j'ai jamais été un grand
fan de boue
je subis même un peu mes repas je sais
que pas mal de gens comme ça on a parlé
beaucoup est avec cette d'ailleurs de ça
je subis un peu mes repas je mange parce
qu'il faut manger j'ai pas le plaisir
culinaire même même de consommateurs du
coup pour moi c'est dur de passer une
heure et quelques à faire un truc et
d'avoir quasiment le même plaisir quand
je le mange que quand je passe cinq
minutes à faire les copier après c'était
une expérience très intéressante
j'ai appris à faire des radios je vous
remercie merci au chef aussi qui a été
incroyable cela je vais les conserver je
ne mangerai ce soir en vrai c'est mon
jab j'ai pas envie de lâcher je vais les
manger ils pourraient être un peu plus
cuit mais je pense quand même que c'est
manger avec eux je risque rien puis
j'adore la tapenade donc en vrai ça
parce que j'aime mais voilà c'était très
cool si vous voulez suivre la recette du
chef et moi et mon loyer mes photos du
résultat bat ne le fait pas je les ai
vécus lie avec la pâte à modeler avec la
peinture tous ceux qui m'envoie une
photo quand ils l'ont fait c'est que
ceux qui sont fiers de ce qu'ils ont
fait donc le résultat à chaque fois et
mieux que moi donc mon ego et brisé un
peu plus à chaque fois fait mort a
violement gellé ya pas de problème je ne
veux rien recevoir à bientôt continue à
rester chez vous bien évidemment tout ça
plein de bonnes vibes et puis on se
retrouve bientôt dans une autre vidéo un
peu moins catastrophique j'espère c'est
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]